das ist unser Internet das kommt das
läuft durchs bet von der Funkantenne
hier dann
m über den Hof und dort zum Fenster rein
und sie haben Kabel das dann da in ihr
Fenster ja ja reingeht ja in ihr Windows
quasi könnte man sagen ne genau aber wo
führt denn das Kabel hin ja ist ein
kleines Stück wir sind da ja wir sind da
endlich wow
unfassbar was ist das da kommt das
Signal an
dass dort in ein kilomet Entfernung vom
Bauernhof gesendet wird also das heißt
sie zapfen eigentlich das Internet von
Bauern da drüben ja das tun mehrere ja
das ist legal und absolut so gewollt
aber diese Bäume das Wachstum der Bäume
macht mir Sorgen wenn diese buchen
wachsen und dann im Frühjahr ab Frühjahr
Blätter haben dann haben wir keine
Sichtachse mehr zu dieser zu diesem
Sendeteil des Bauern und dann ist
Schluss mit Internet